these are the ones that like each other
before don't like you today hey guys
it's Kylie and Jordan and we're here
answering some of your fan questions
with puppies the show is pretty much a
long snapchat story it's just really a
different side of us more personal side
and I'm just excited for people to see
that honestly I can't even think with
this cuteness going on me and Jordan met
through mutual friends one day I got a
phone call from one of my friends and
they're like yeah come over to Kylie's
house we all want to hang out I'm like
and she put her name in my phone
and we just got closer and closer
throughout the years and realized all we
need is each other and and you'll get it
now out of nowhere our only friend we
used to Segway everywhere I mean
everywhere when we didn't have our
license like we would Segway outside the
community to like miles and miles to the
mall probably turning 21 like that's fun
you know I never had a drink before want
to know what it's like I'm gonna say Kim
I feel like I go to different sisters
for different problems and right now me
and Kim have just then really eating a
lot and talking it honestly it changes
everyday
so tomorrow it'll probably somebody new
but Kim renounce my faith well I think
Kendall would be mad at me
in second though so what do you think
amusement park gonna puppy really
everything I can't do so I would love to
just go have lunch
maybe shop this is not okay because you
know how I am with puppies like I'm
gonna should we take all of them like I
really am gonna go get a puppy right now
I love Bill Nye the Science Guy for real
he is sexy
I tell you it's very daddy I'm but if I
had to say someone else probably yeah
it's only bill that we tried to take a
picture with him once I saw him walking
down the street and he said no I totally
understand
when you just want to say no but like we
were really excited Kendall is killing
it Bella Hadid is killing it can just
pretty much like my friends and family I
look for me I just I find my style and
spoke to Mike random things like people
walking down the street or anyone on
Instagram where I'm like oh they're cool
I want to wear my thing like this too or
I wouldn't say there's one person in
particular for me
I literally read crazy things about me
like all day every day so I can't really
think of anything specifically but
probably just that like I am getting
married all the time
or I don't know just I read too many
things I can't keep track
this isn't fair they like this dress
they really think my dress I think it's
very cushy and cozy
I got extensions lash extensions and
moisturizer I cannot live without
pollution I can't live without lipstick
if I forget the lipstick at home it's
the one thing I will turn around I'm
sorry I know you want to leave but he
makes so much noise
I would always over line my lips when I
was like 16 and all my fans would be
like what color are you wearing that's
all my comments section would you say
like what lipstick color are you wearing
so I just thought why not make my own
reality shows I really only watch
keeping up or life of Kylie has kept me
entertained
I do been binge watch a lot of other
shows like Handmaid's Tale I'm always
trying to find new shows I really try
hard to take my makeup completely off
like I need to get every inch of my face
I need to clean my lashes I put on
sunscreen every morning I can't wear a
lot of moisturizer because it breaks my
face out unfortunately I don't know what
people think about it because I tend to
not look at it just a lot I feel of it
all wrong sometimes I think they have it
almost everything wrong everything
except for 11 cosmetics
[Music]
it was pretty deep but there wasn't a
lot of weights and Kim kind of threw a
tantrum like immediately when she found
out that she lost it and I was like no
this is fine I went under there and it
was salt water so it kind of hurt to
open my eyes but I just opened my eyes
and looked around and I saw something
shining swam all the way down there was
like ten feet picked it up and it was
the shining diamond it was literally
found it in two minutes I think you have
a future career and then I was she was
like I have just you know I don't have
my backing but it's fine I can always
get that and I was like I'm just gonna
look so I went back down I found the
backing
I found the earring backing she was like
you were just future career I'm telling
you diamond finder dive team this was
one of the best interviews I hope we
weren't too distracted but thanks for
sticking through it
oh I'm smart and I see I'm too
distracted all right it's been real and
now
you've been plotting to get in the song
so far honest not be something you just
remind me of a puppy I wanted in a pet
store one time
[Music]